welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of one
division episode four
an episode ripped straight from the
headlines of new rockstars videos the
fact that
let's just add in here ah that's better
there were a ton
of details in this episode that you
might have missed i'm gonna break them
all down shot by
shot spoiler warning let's get started
the episode opens with now one of my
favorite mcu sequences
a walking dead opening scene style
hospital panic showing us the moment of
the blip return
one of those snap victims monica rambo
re-materializes
this all occurs simultaneously with
avengers in game the moment hulk
reverses snap
and it's pure chaos we did see a bit of
this undusting in spider-man far from
home when a tuba player got wrecked
this time it's this poor rematerialized
dope
to the sound added for comedic effect
but listen closely to these opening
seconds
now that last line is the voice of carol
danvers taken directly from the captain
marvel film
when they were handing out kids they
gave her the toughest one
lieutenant trouble in the comics
lieutenant trouble was captain marvel's
nickname for kit renner but in the mcu
it is their nickname for the young
monica rambo but the lines before that
suggests monica's mother maria rambo
callsign photon from captain marvel had
to
leave monica behind to be raised by her
grandmother at some point
sounds like there was a space mission
with carol danvers maybe connected with
the skrulls
and or the origins of sword maybe
something we will see in captain marvel
2 or maybe something that actually led
to maria's cancer later in her life now
the close-up imagery of monica's
particles coming back together
is gloriously rendered dare i say even
better looking than an
infinity war notable difference though
monica's pieces are not desaturated
they're not
ashes just like bits of her
this evokes joe quesadas amazing art of
wanda
in the house of m comics that we think
this whole show is based on among this
chaos we see one guy re-materializing
beside a hospital bed and assuming he
dusted five years earlier
he would be a total stranger to whoever
this woman is there's another patient
reappearing in a hospital bed i love it
this is all horrifying as it would be
despite the russo saying that
it was just like a peaceful return on
the other side of hulk snap
next sword sentient weapon observation
response division this is headquartered
on a coastal base that looks a lot like
cape canaveral
shuttle launch pads and that big old
hangar it's
massive compare that to the size of the
nearby office building this
could be where sword built pieces of the
peak space station which
might be where nick fury was in that
part from home post credit scene since
one division is apparently set three
weeks after endgame this would be
around november 2023 and far from home
is set in summer 2024
giving half a year or so to get that
space station operational if it isn't
already the lobby is laid out similarly
to
shields old triskelion in dc sword might
have grown as an
offshoot sister organization under the
leadership of maria rambo
throughout the 90s and 2000s while fury
was overrunning shield on the screens
news comes from w-h-i-h
that's the end universe mcu news service
that we saw in promos for ant-man
there's also a
spectrum news spectrum is one of the
superhero names monica rambo takes on
as an avenger in the comics and darcy
later tracks monica with a spectrum
analyzer we may be seeing
spectrum's origin story as a future
avenger in the mcu now monica wears this
necklace
looks like a small golden sword pendant
this might be what turns into the
necklace in west view
i think it's this more than the new
lanyard id badge she gets
just because it sounds like sword is her
home it's really her last connection to
her mother this pendant represents that
and westview is kind of
expressing that history now with this
sword necklace that she can't separate
herself from and then monica's met by
acting sword director tyler hayward
calling it now
[ __ ] this dude he easily could have
activated her id but instead he had her
feel like an outsider so that he could
swoop in as a white knight and escort
her in
he clearly feels threatened by her post
blip return he thought she would never
come back he's kind of like brad
against peter parker he knows the status
he has should belong to her and now he's
apparently throwing her to this
assignment hoping she will get erased
from this world i think
i mean isn't it suspicious that fbi
agent jimmy wu
lost someone in federal witness
protection someone whose past associates
claim not to
know suddenly and now hayward is
throwing his all-star
agent monica rambo at this i'm beginning
to think hayward could have set
all this up like he might have made a
deal with a devil that mystery
missing persons that jimmy wu was
looking for whom i think
could be agnes ralph and hayward did
this to raise his status at sword while
helping that kaiser soze slip through
the cracks
to hijack an unstable infinity stone
irradiated avenger
to create a pocket reality where she
could resurrect her corpse boo and make
babies
oh wow that devil figure drains her of
her power but now it has blown up in
hayward's face
and he doesn't know what to do i mean
i'm just saying wayward hayward knows
quite a bit about ancient
cosmic radiation my equipment registered
an extremely high level of cmbr
that's relic radiation dating back to
the big bang and uh not to go too hex
crazy on this guy but the diplomas on
his wall
are arranged in a ring of six if i lost
it i'm just probing a fake town with
drones till something sticks
now depending on what time of day you're
watching this video your eyes might
start to feel real tired i know my eyes
feel that way i've been staring at a
screen all day which is why i'm so
grateful for
blue blocks for sponsoring this video so
if you're anything like me you're
logging more screen time than ever right
now
all that staring at a computer or a
phone makes my eyes feel real heavy and
can
wreck my sleep when i'm up late trying
to finish a video turns out this is
caused by the blue
light emitted by screens blue light
leads to digital eye strain
and can cause symptoms like blurred
vision headaches and eyes that are
either too dry or too watery and all
this could even impact your mood and
energy level well blue blocks was
created to fix this problem and block
out the blue light with high quality
lenses
they're made under optics laboratory
conditions in australia
in line with the suggested peer-reviewed
academic literature
they have over 40 hip frames and come in
prescription non-prescription and
readers now i've been wearing their
brooklyn computer glasses i also have
these uh cali summer glow glasses that
use color therapy to combat seasonal
affective disorder blueblocks gives back
by working in partnership with restoring
vision
in their buy one gift one campaign for
each pair of blue blocks glasses
purchased
they donate a pair of reading glasses to
someone in need so go to blueblocks.com
new rockstars and use the promo code new
rockstars at checkout
to get 20 off and free shipping
worldwide get your
energy back sleep better and block out
the unhealthy effects of blue light with
blue blocks that's b
l u b l o x dot com slash new rockstars
or just click on the link below to get
free shipping worldwide in 20 off your
order
but as i was saying oh i feel so
dramatic taking on my glasses as i say
that the two catch up
how are the numbers for the astronaut
training program dismal
lost half my person on the blip and half
of those remaining have lost their nerve
interesting sword test pilots sound like
a possible setup for the fantastic four
whom we know are coming to the mcu
hayward says
shifted away from manned missions and we
focused on robotics
nanotech ai sentient weapons like it
says on the door
it also says observation and response on
that door
it's not creation what you're telling me
sword was creating
sentient weapons yeah definitely evoke
some notes of
weapon x or some kind of way for the
mutants to join the mcu
and then this world's not the same as
you left it
space is now full of unexpected threats
always was full of threats and allies
monica's allies sound like her scroll
friends
boom maybe not everyone will see us
allies we know from far from home things
are about to skew into a cree scroll war
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top secret information
then monica meets jimmy wu james e woo
fbi nice jimmy does some close-up magic
a trick that he learned from scott
lang's close-up magic class in the
ant-man and the wasp
how'd you do it scott do what the car
trick
sir can you knock now these east view
cops
deny west view even exist but my
question is does
east view exist were these cops expelled
from westview their car
warped their minds brainwashed so that
westview would have no law enforcement
and thus be more vulnerable to a hostile
takeover
some possible number details here
monica's suv is numbered 8512 maybe for
the 1985-12
issue comic run some believe one
division is based on her drone is
numbered as
57 maybe for avengers issue 57 the debut
of the vision and some are pointing out
that the helicopter is the same color
scheme as captain marvel but you know i
think that's also just kind of generic
colors
dr darcy lewis returns from the thor
movies now contracted by sword alongside
these other experts in other fields
artificial intelligence um artificial
intelligence ai was mentioned as one of
the new sword disciplines hayward
highlighted earlier
shifted away from manned missions and we
focused on robotics
nanotech ai darcy scans of radiation
coming from westview what are you
getting
a colossal amount of cmbr cmbr
is the oldest electromagnetic radiation
in the universe it does date back to the
big bang
and it's actually the same kind of
radiation that creates tv static
thus the staticky border membrane of the
town but the big bang connection is key
because as wang told us in infinity war
that is how we got these things
big banks and six elemental crystals
huddling across the virgin universe
remember wanda's powers were activated
by one of those infinity stones a mine
stone
and this whole universe just went
through four shock waves of that same
kind of cosmic radiation
which could all be connected to this new
anomaly hayward sends agent franklin
to find monica via the sewers showing
how we got our beekeeper
wu doesn't like the plan there's no
reason to suspect the perimeter doesn't
extend subterraneously
there's no reason to suspect it does
yeah jimmy woo is saying that the pocket
reality extends
beneath the surface another sign that
this hell mouth might be coming from
below
the town perimeter is the shape of a
hexagon confirming our paranoid
suspicion about all the hexagonal
imagery it really may just be that this
whole town is
a hex by one a spell darcy queues up the
sitcom feed confirming that she was that
notetaker watching at the end of episode
one
look i know it's been a crazy few years
on this planet but
he's dead right not blipped
dead i just point this out because that
sword agent behind them is
loving this sitcom forget the jimmy wu
parallels with me i would totally be
that guy oh by the way quick update that
our merch partners epicure labs hit 10
000 subscribers and that means they just
gave away a playstation 5. check it out
so we're just uh
calling to let you know that you uh you
just won a playstation 5.
no way yes way now there are still
nine more playstation 5's to go so keep
on entering by subscribing to epic hero
labs and going to epiccaroshop.com
giveaway to officially enter we'll
announce a new winner every 10 000
subscribers right here but speaking of
our merch partners i am wearing our
wanda vision inspired latest obsession
shirt which you can find at
newrockstarsmerch.com or
epicheroshop.com
it's got some cool augmented reality
easter eggs and it's a limited edition
which means it's not like the real
vision who seemingly cannot die
when this shirt is gone it is gone head
to newrockstarsmerge.com to grab this
shirt or a new rockstar's beanie or a
new rockstars coaster all of which help
support this channel so the sword
operatives are able to id the hearts as
todd and sharon davis sharon davis is
actually the name of an art director on
wandavision
herb is john collins the name of another
art director on the show
actually later the 70s credits say
produced by liam patrick
she is a post-production supervisor for
the show it's fun all the names the cast
and crew are names of actual crew
working for marvel
norm is avalosh tandon and if you look
closely at the notes on his form
avalash expresses concern for his father
and sister this information was obtained
when vision awakened him
is wanted controlling the whole town
physical safety of residents is now in
question
when vision restores him avalash becomes
norm again well hold on
vision awakened him when did this happen
was this a lost episode
it kind of sounds like what vision does
to agnes in trailer footage
am i dead no if this is based on house
of m
vision might be playing a kind of
wolverine role awakening
warped person after warped person within
this alternate reality until the walls
come crumbling down
agnes gets pinned to the board but no
new jersey id was found for her
suggesting she might not be a true west
view victim but someone working with the
darker forces to manipulate wanda dottie
is also missing but you know this is
still a work in progress her photo isn't
at all on the wall they might not have
printed out her photo yet but a lot of
people are thinking she might also be uh
kind of key to westview some people are
saying she's playing clia
now of course everyone's talking about
this jimmy wu's notes are clearly meta
jokes about the questions we have
literally been asking this is
wild our video titles and thumbnails
have been asking about hexagons
why sitcoms vision alive or not but
there's a lot of details here the board
mentions a five
mile radius which might explain why
exterior stuff
outside of west view like those east
view cops and the highway sign remain
warped as well
and then under the possible perpetrators
of this skrulls
yes this confirms that jimmy wu and all
these feds
know that squirrels exist now jimmy
brings them up as possible
antagonists which contradicts the
friendly relationship with the scrolls
shared by nick fury and the rambos while
many squirrels are
friendly it does sound like some
authorities view parts of the skrull
race as a threat
they tried to contact wanda so you've
seen that radio on wanda's kitchen
counter right
the next time she's washing dishes which
by my account happens about
once an episode barf barf nice little
shout out to stark's hollow projection
tech that i hope is not part of this
but also once per episode how many
episodes have they seen
based on their footage of monica from
that 60's era there are other lost
episodes so can we see
them please now from darcy's point of
view dotty's whole glass shattered from
episode 2 is totally skipped over
how does a housewife get a blood stain
out of weight this happens later with
monica's expulsion so who
is editing this feed i'm thinking it
might just be wanda herself based on the
way she patches that hole in her house
but still we know there are some
elements of this reality that wanda
cannot control we also see the beekeeper
moment
his cable turns into a jump rope but we
don't see what happens to him when wanda
rewinds
some believe he might have been warped
into that ice cream guy from episode
three but that was a different actor
than zach henry they normally don't like
change their
faces i just assumed he might have been
reversed back out through that sewer
tunnel and the aspect ratio
widens as wanda ejects monica using her
red chaos magic to smash her through the
living room the nursery
the outside fence and the whole west
view border so that's one two three
four wanda literally broke monica
through the fourth wall
then in case your pants are too dry
even more unsettling than the grey
corpse vision from infinity war it's the
fact that he just reverts to normal with
a simple cut
back like nothing happened and thus can
happen again
any [ __ ] time we cut back to him but
this tells us that the version of vision
that exists in the real world is as
darcy said
dead dead he is a corpse that wanda
could be trying to reanimate with
sorcery so if he has been a corpse the
whole time does that mean that wanda
banged a robot corpse in episode two
hold on to your dead horse's necrophiles
your nasty
i don't think all these people are being
ragdolled around with just like
sit-commie sleeves
over them it's more like once you're in
the bubble all
of reality within this bubble shifts as
a whole like your whole body
re-materializes to be whatever wanda
imagines you to be
wherever she wants you to be doing
whatever she wants you to do but yeah
vision is dead folks and i think
westview's hexagonal shape tells us that
this
is a town-wide hex spell all to try to
resurrect vision's corpse
using the cosmic radiation from wanda's
infinity stone activated powers
may be further enhanced by the recent
shock waves of the same kind of cosmic
radiation and despite monica saying
it's all wanda i think jimmy wu's whole
missing person mystery
being the start of all this tells us
that wanda is not doing this
alone at least agnes and someone else
may be ralph
they want her to be doing this jimi
hendrix's voodoo child plays over the
credits a nod to the true
witchcraft at play here but watch
vision's eyes
in the final seconds he is nervously
looking over at wanda
and then his head lowers but his eye
line raises over the tv
he is looking at us he wants
out hey uh by the way now that we're not
getting episodes early the fastest we
can get these videos out
are inside marvel episodes friday midday
breakdowns on saturdays it's kind of
like uh the coverage we did with the
mandalorian this is how we always do it
but a new thing we're doing is that you
can join our live tapings of inside
marvel every friday 8am pacific on
stereo we will answer your questions in
real time it's fun
and dory this is not delaying or
replacing any of our youtube content
it's just something extra that we're
doing for you guys you can join us at
stereo
dot com slash new rockstars follow me on
instagram at ea boss follow me rockstars
subscribe new rockstars on youtube for
breakdowns of all your wanna vision what
the [ __ ]
see you next week when one division
makes fun of our brand spots for aqua
socks
[Music]
you